I'm saying like I I guess my point was  that like a lot of men aren't uh bred  almost like from childhood to to  anticipate someone wanting to have sex  with them like as as a as the initial  point of contact in the relationship  whereas women are women are constantly  from like I can I can literally like  almost recite conversations that I had  when I was like in elementary school  where it was like by the way  growing up somebody's gonna somebody's  gonna want something for you and you  have to it's it creates a mindset of  anticipation which and creates a mindset  of hypersexuality which has this effect  that people are talking about but to me  to me I think that's honest that's true  men do want to have sex like again when  you when you hit 55 or whatever day your  looks go you know um The World's Gonna  treat you different especially men men  absolutely and women talk about this  when they're in their late 50s 60s that  like men treat you that you get way less  attention from Men